it was darkness that made me realize I
had to make a change and I think that's
very common for people who are in dark
spaces you realize if I you know I'm at
a fork in the road I either have to
affect change or I don't know how this
plays out but it's not good you know and
I think a lot of people have faced that
fork um I was very lucky I had a friend
there to hold space for me which gave me
courage goes back goes back again to
Friendship um but uh um but if we sort
of take it something more more recent um
you know for example I didn't write
anything during Co and everybody was
like did you use the time during Co to
write a book and the answer was no
that's I I can't write that way I need
human interaction and so it was it was a
creative you know sort
of cemetery for me there was no big
Ideas um nothing worth writing about
anyway um uh and um I don't believe in
writer's block I believe that you're in
the wrong environment for creativity to
happen and so I think a lot of people
when they run out of ideas or they get
stuck they blame themselves I don't I
blame my environment um and so that's
easy to change because it can't change
me but I can change my environment um
and so for example this year I wasn't
having any ideas and I tried different
things and it wasn't working and so I
did I took a risk and I moved to another
country for 11 weeks I moved to the UK
for 11 weeks for no other reason than to
shake things up and see what happens and
the ideas bubbled it's absolutely
wonderful so I'm a great believer in
changing your routine doing something
different putting your desk in a
different in a different way you know
and start inviting a friend over I did
I've done this one as well a friend who
is in a completely different line of
business who has nothing to what I do
because we so many of us are working
from home by ourselves find another
friend who works from home by themselves
who might be in a completely different
company work together and simply sit in
the room together it's amazing what
happens the ideas that flow and just
having a work Buddy things like that
experiment with entirely new different
ways of working not all of them will
work and you find the one that works for
you and when that stops working you try
something new again